- Oh my God, I cannot do a pull up.
Sometimes it's really hard
to find time to work out,
but decades of research shows
that the stress that
exercise puts on the body
actually trains it to fend
off major chronic conditions,
like diabetes, cancer,
obesity, and heart disease.
Here we go.
This is hard and it increases
our ability to be independent
as we age.
But let's fact check that.
- [Trainer] Go, go, go.
You got it.
- I took two clinical
stress tests. Oh my God.
And of course, did lots
and lots of exercise.
The goal was to see how much
I could improve my chances
of longevity with some
pretty intense workouts.
This is not fun.
It is so hot out here.
Let's see how it goes.
(car whooshing)
Heather Milton is a clinical
exercise physiologist
at the NYU Langone
Sports Performance Center
and for this experiment,
my longevity trainer.
- So we're doing the
stressor of the exercise
but then allowing you
the adaptation process
and the lower heart rate in between,
which essentially suppresses stressors.
- [Daniela] This first test
is going to give us our baseline
for my longevity-related metrics.
First, we tracked my heart rate recovery
or how quickly my heart rate
came down from its peak.
For that, we used a
simple heart rate monitor.
The other metric is VO2 max,
which is the maximum rate
at which your heart, lungs,
and muscles use oxygen.
That was measured with this
sensor that ingested the air
I was breathing into the tubed mask.
- This is gonna be tighter.
- [Daniela] Oxygen
consumption should be low
for light walking
because that shouldn't
really take that much effort.
Every 30 seconds or so, the
treadmill got faster and steeper
during the test and my
oxygen consumption went up.
- Give it your all. Where are you now?
All right.
Almost there. Almost.
- [Daniela] After running
for about nine minutes,
I had to stop.
My heart rate peaked at
167 beats per minute.
- Stay on the treadmill.
It's gonna come down.
I'm gonna watch that heart rate response.
You currently already have a nice VO2,
so I wanna see that it's above 26.
Yours was 38.6.
- [Daniela] That's
equal to the milliliters
of oxygen consumed per kilogram
of your weight each minute.
My heart rate recovery was
only seven beats per minute.
Ideally, it'd be at least 12.
- Recovery is really important
because that's when we're
allowing our body to process all
of the stressors that we put in
and then make the adaptations
to become bigger, faster, stronger.
- [Daniela] On to test number two.
I did a series of heavier
and heavier leg presses.
- Press, press, press,
press, press, press, press.
There you go.
- I maxed out at 205 pounds.
That gave us a sense of my
muscle and joint strength,
which directly relates
to having good balance
and having good balance helps avoid falls,
one of the biggest factors for
preventable deaths as we age.
So with all that info,
Heather put together this
10-day fitness plan for me,
focusing on cardio and strength training.
I expected a challenge and to sweat.
That was hard.
But even on this short
10-day fitness plan,
I still ran into a few issues
because the weights I
have are not optimal.
(Daniela grunting)
- I wanna see the video.
- My GoPro overheated.
86 degrees.
I'm not gonna go outside
because the air quality
is terrible out there.
I probably should have
picked a better time
to make this video, like when
I wasn't traveling for work.
- [Captain] We wanna welcome you to Miami.
- But I think that's the
reality for most people.
We squeeze in a workout
whenever we can, and I'm done.
Tomorrow I go back to NYU
for my final stress test.
Hopefully, all of that hard
work over the last 10 days
has paid off.
- All right. Ready to go?
(Daniela grunting)
You're in control.
You tell me when you
absolutely reach that max.
Otherwise, keep going.
You got this. Everything looks great.
- My VO2 max didn't change, as expected.
Heather says, improvements in VO2 max
take at least six to eight weeks.
It requires a lot of complex
cardiovascular changes,
so things like heart
tissue getting stronger,
lungs taking in more oxygen,
blood vessels becoming more elastic
and new, healthier red blood cells
to deliver oxygen to muscles.
We did see other related improvements.
- You're able to do a minute more,
which means you're able
to achieve more work
and a faster pace without
getting to your maximal exertion.
- [Daniela] And that meant
my body got more efficient
at using oxygen.
- The higher your fitness level is,
the lower the effort level is
or the lower the ask for your
body for those general tasks.
- [Daniela] Simple things
like walking around, working,
putting away groceries and cleaning.
- And your heart rate recovery
was much more better too.
- Mine went from seven
to 21 beats per minute.
I was a little less confident though
about the leg press because
for most of the experiment.
I mean, I didn't have weights, right?
I had my two laptops and children.
I can only do five reps of you.
- [Heather] Two, three.
- The first one felt like feathers.
- Yeah, that's a good sign.
- We started at 65 pounds
and went up from there.
I finished the test at 245 pounds,
40 pounds higher than before.
I guess hard work pays off.
(Daniela chuckling)
Strength training is also important
for improving insulin sensitivity
and maintaining healthy
blood glucose levels.
That can stave off some
of those big killers
I mentioned earlier, things
like diabetes and obesity.
Scientists don't yet know
what the optimal amount
of exercise for each
person is, but generally,
they recommend 150 minutes of
moderate exercise per week.
A 10-year study of 650,000 adults showed
that those who got at least 75 minutes
of exercise lived 1.8 years
longer than inactive adults.
People who worked out five to
eight hours a week lived more
than four years longer.
So I was in that range.
There's no way to say
how many years my 10 days
of intense workouts added to my life.
But according to this
study, sedentary people age.
they did from being
self-sufficient to dependent,
much sooner than active people.
So if I keep up with my workouts,
I could increase the time
I'm healthy and independent
by more than a decade.
So what can you do if you
wanna start working out
towards a healthier, longer life
but don't have access to
fancy trainers and tests?
Wearables are a good place to start.
They can track metrics like
VO2 max, heart rate recovery
and walking steadiness pretty accurately.
Heather said that your heart rate data
is the easiest way to go.
Your resting heart rate
should become lower
as your fitness level improves.
Exercise is generally good for your health
but too much can also
be counterproductive.
For me, the hardest part was
just getting off the couch,
though now that I'm not
getting paid to work out,
it is harder.
So good luck out there.
(lively music)